bonsoir à tous les messieurs merci
d'être avec nous ce soir sur rtl france
alors sébastien chenu 1 ce matin le
porte parole du rassemblement national
estime qu'il faut vivre avec le virus
j'imagine que c'est votre avis aussi
nicolas maisonnée
bien sûr on écouter absolument bon vous
avez rappelé que nous avons nous étions
contre les élus du rassemblement
national les députés marine le pen nous
étions contre le pass sanitaire parce
que nous estimions qu'il ne serait pas
d'abord efficace et d'une part et
d'autre part qui serait gravement
attentatoire au principe de liberté que
qu'il s'agissait d'ailleurs d'une
obligation vaccinale des 10es est
également attentatoire au principe
d'égalité puisque il ya désormais deux
types de citoyens le citoyen vaccinés
qui à son passé sanitaires et qui aura
son passage actional et le citoyen non
vaccinés qui lui sera sera privé de
droit donc évidemment nous sommes nous
sommes contre ce se passe maximale mais
nous nous défendons toujours la liberté
vaccinale donc nous ne sommes pas contre
le vaccin maintenant nous observons une
chose qui je crois saute aux yeux de
tout le monde d'aujourd'hui c'est que le
vaccin n'est pas le produit miracle
qu'on nous a vendu il n'empêche pas la
transmission il permet une protection
individuelle qu'il ne faut pas négliger
mais qui est somme toute relatif
puisqu'il ya aujourd'hui dans les
hôpitaux dans les services de
réanimation des personnes également
vaccinés mais nous nous invitons les
français à être adulte ce qu'ils sont et
à faire le choix du rapport bénéfice
risque qui est le leur vincent chauvet
vous jouez réagir à ce que ce qui était
en train de dire notre nicolas
maisonnais ce soir une atteinte
l'égalité une atteinte à la liberté
qu'est ce que vous en pensez justement
alors l'atteinte à la liberté elle est
relativement évidente et
justement comme l'a dit damien abad des
républicains eh bien il faut trouver le
bon équilibre entre liberté et
protection sanitaire et moi il me semble
assez évident qu'il faut limiter dans le
temps on verra ce que décide le
parlement moi je salue le travail en ce
moment des parlementaires votre
journaliste a dit que les oppositions
aller voter contre gmail nuance le parti
socialiste et les républicains sont en
train de contribuer et à priori votre on
en faveur du texte ce sont les extrêmes
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite qui
sont contre les l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale dans sa
composante modérée est en train de
contribuer sur ce texte
ensuite la rupture d'égalité non tout le
citoyen est égal devant le virus est
malheureusement égales devant la ksa ou
là où l'autre comme vous voulez la
différence de traitement et c'est ce que
garantit la constitution elle se fait
sur des différences de situation il ya
des gens qui ont choisi d'être vacciné
il ya des gens qui ont choisi de ne pas
être vaccinés eh bien chacun est traité
d'une manière différente pendant cette
période épidémique ça me semble tout à
fait normal est tout à fait compatible
en tout cas avec le principe d'égalité
la liberté oui et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut que ce soit le plus proportionnée
possible et le plus temporaire possible
je pense que l'ensemble des forces que
ce soit le centre et le modem vous avez
vu lui a fait des propositions
le centre gauche avec les socialistes ou
la droite républicaine s'accordent sur
ce point alors on dit vive le rap est un
tout à l'heure le but de ce projet de
passes vaccinale explique il est proposé
un pour sauver des vies et non pour
restreindre est des libertés une formule
avec laquelle vous n'êtes pas d'accord
j'imagine nicolas mais jamais
mais je voudrais je voudrais réagir à
mon contradicteur aux propos de mon
contradicteur et qui sait tout de suite
empressé de qualifier d' extrémistes
mon propos ça c'est vous voyez c'est on
est dans l'argument classique de canton
n'a pas d'argument oncle affi on
qualifie son adversaire deux
extrémistes voire même peut-être
pourquoi pas de fascistes oui c'est vrai
qu'il faut qu'il y ait un équilibre
entre les mesures de protection et les
libertés mais on a déjà fait
l'expérience du passé ni terre et
aujourd'hui nous en sommes à plus de 210
cas par jour c'est dire à quel point la
mesure du pas salutaire et est
absolument inefficace qu'est ce que le
pass vaccinale du tout moi va apporter
de plus écoutez tout simplement l' oms
le dit le directeur de l'ot le dit lui
même on ne réglera pas cette pandémie à
grands coups de rappel de l'accès à tous
je veux dire que
ça coule de source c'est évident on a
évidemment un nombre de cas qui
explosent et en arrière-plan si vous
voulez la vérité c'est quoi c'est con à
la crise de l'hôpital et qu'on a peur
d'engorger les hôpitaux or aujourd'hui
il ya 3500 personnes en france en
réanimation 3500 personnes ça veut dire
à peu près 35 personnes par par par
département donc ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui notre pays ne serait pas
en mesure d'accueillir 35 personnes
avaient réuni mation dans chaque
département nous la sixième puissance
mondiale nous dans le système de santé a
été vantée dans le dans le monde entier
on voit bien que aujourd'hui il ya une
difficulté qui se situe au niveau de
l'hôpital et là le gouvernement une
véritable responsabilité puisqu'ils ont
fermé cinq mille 700 lits en 2020 dit
7500 lits ont été fermés sous emmanuel
macron et maintenant ils suspendent
15000 soignants 15me soignants sous
prétexte qu'ils ne sont pas vaccinés à
leurs conneries il aurait très bien pu
exercer leur travail tout en se faisant
tester puisque le larmes ultime dans
cette gestion de crise c'est bien le
test quelqu'un qui n'est pas vacciné
mais qui est testé négatif est toujours
moins dangereux que quelqu'un qui est
vacciné et testés positifs ans
aujourd'hui on est même en train de
rappeler
des soignants positif d'un certain
hôpitaux pour aller exercer par pénurie
de médecins vous voyez bien qu'on marche
sur la tête évidemment les
vincent chauvet justement sur sur la sur
la question je vous voyais également
réagir un instant sur sur les chiffres 1
énumérés par par nicolas mais onem il ya
une question nicolas dazet vous avez
posé tout à l'heure et qui me semble
important puisque vous êtes sûrement pas
le seul à vous là à vous la poser qu'est
ce que le pass vaccinale va apporter de
plus vincent chauvet
non monsieur le député a raison quand il
dit que effectivement le but c'est de ne
pas engorger le système hospitalier et
on sait que ça peut aller très vite et
que ça peut faire boule de neige et que
des services qui sont peut-être à 30 40
pour cent de leur capacité maximale
peuvent très vite être saturé à 100 101
% et ensuite on a des brancards dans les
couloirs on a des gens qu'on n'arrive
plus à traiter et là on a une vraie
rupture d'égalité pour le coup est hélas
notre promesse républicaine d'une santé
pour tous ces fous complètement
aujourd'hui il ya une maman de médecins
en france c'est très clair il ya
peut-être un manque d'investissement
dans l'hôpital public mais on ferme des
lits par manque aussi de médecins et on
sait qui a aussi beaucoup de lit en ce
moment qui sont fermées parce que on
n'arrive pas à recruter moi je peux vous
dire qu'à l'hôpital d'ottawa je suis
président du conseil de surveillance si
on avait plus de médecins on pourrait
ouvrir plus de lits bon il ya une
pénurie générale est donc le pass
sanitaire le pass vaccinale maintenant
et c'est d'éviter cet effet boule de
neige pour ne pas saturer nos hôpitaux
publics néanmoins on va déjà des
situations très tendues j'étais tout à
l'heure avec des autunois de la commune
qui vont être déprogrammé le plan blanc
ça veut dire aussi qu'on des probables
des gens qui devait se faire opérer par
exemple de cancer de la vessie ou autre
et dont on va des programmes et
l'opération c'est à dire que ça il
faudrait qu'ils attendent un mois deux
mois trois mois en espérant que les leur
situation n'évolue pas défavorablement
voilà ce qu'on essaye d'éviter et
aujourd'hui on le voit les lits de
réanimation
dans mon hôpital n'y a pas de lits de
réanimation pourtant il ya des personnes
co-lead parce que tout le monde
heureusement développe pas de forme
grave mais en tout cas il ya aussi
beaucoup de monde qui occupent des lits
et qui occupent des places d'hôpitaux et
qui occupe du temps médical parce qu'ils
sont malades et il faut le dire très
majoritairement 80% des fois parce
qu'ils ne sont pas vaccinés et
aujourd'hui on a un engorgement des
hôpitaux par des gens qui ne sont pas
vaccinés donc le pass vaccinale ils
essaient de limiter les contaminations
et puis ils essayent de faire que les
gens qui jusqu'à présent se tester
systématiquement pour avoir le pass
sanitaire finalement franchissent le pas
du test vers la vaccination et puis de
convaincre peut-être une frange on sait
qu'il ya encore 0 5 % de français qui
chaque semaine pour leur première
injection est bien de convaincre un peu
plus ces français qui sont pas des
réfractaires absolue mais qui sont
majoritairement peut-être celtique ou en
tout cas encore en attente et bien deux
de se faire vacciner de basculer dans
les 90 % de la de la population qui
aujourd'hui et est vacciné éligibles
avant de se quitter ou une question sur
laquelle j'aurais aimé entendre votre
avis à tous les deux on sait que l'étau
se resserre de plus en plus sur les
personnes non vaccinées actuellement
notamment avec l'application prochaine
improbable de ce pass vaccinale
l'obligation vaccinale en france est-ce
qu'on va y arriver un jour est ce que
est ce que c est ce que ce pass
vaccinale et des gens quelque sorte une
obligation vaccinale très rapidement je
vous donne la parole à tous les deux
avec nicolas à maisonnais tout d'abord
écouter bien sûr c'est une évidemment
que c'est une obligation vaccinale
déguisé sauf qu'on ne veut pas à mon
avis passé à l'obligation vaccinale
parce que cela poserait une question qui
est très importante c'est la question de
la responsabilité juridique si l'on
passé à la l'obligation vaccinale est
bien l'état devrait assumer les
éventuels préjudices de cette de cette
vaccination
juste rapidement pour répondre à
monsieur chômé il faut dire que le
vaccin n empêche pas la transmission
donc on n'arrivera pas cette épidémie
avec le pass vaccinale ce qu'il faut
c'est généralisé évidemment les tests et
les rendre évidemment gratuit le test
est bien sûr le meilleur moyen pour
combattre cette épidémie est également
accordée aux médecins la liberté de
prescrire faire confiance à nos médecins
c'est important il faut le dire parce
que depuis 18 mois un peu plus
maintenant on prescrit du doliprane et
évidemment on s'étonne que les résultats
soient médiocre façon j'aurais
l'obligation vaccinale est ce qu'il faut
se pencher sur la question sérieusement
effectivement aujourd'hui dans
l'arbitrage libertés individuelles
sécurité le gouvernement a choisi de ne
pas m'être l'obligation vaccinale
faut-il encore être modeste dans cette
crise et des vérités d'aujourd'hui sont
pas forcément celle de demain moi
j'observe qu'en belgique où je me rends
régulièrement je suis membre du comité
européen des régions et avec des élus
locaux de toute l'union européenne nous
nous retrouvons pour débattre notamment
de ces sujets la belgique réfléchit
désormais à une obligation vaccinale bon
moi je ne suis pas forcément favorable
parce qu'il ya des réfractaires qui de
toute façon même sous la menace d'une
amende ou de gendarmes ne se feront pas
vacciner donc ce qu'il faut faire c'est
que le maximum de personnes soient
vaccinés en parallèle à voir les tests
simplement avoir des traitements et
preiser est en train apparemment des
traitements sur le marché intéressant
mais leur disons le le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui des personnes non
vaccinées en gorge nous services
d'hôpitaux fondé des programmations et
mettre une pression que l'on pourrait
éviter sur notre système de santé si
davantage de gens 6 et 10% 10 15 % de
gens qui ne sont pas encore vaccinés se
vacciner là on très pâle épidémie mais
en tout cas on soulagerait vraiment
l'hôpital et je peux vous dire qu'en ce
moment les soignants sont vraiment
fatiguées et en ont vraiment marre de
voir des gens développer des formes plus
graves qu'ils n'auraient développé s'il
avait été un maximum merci beaucoup
monsieur d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
sur arte france merci à vous vincent
chauvet je rappelle que vous êtes maire
modem d'autant merci également à mon
nico la maisonnée vous êtes député du
rassemblement national dans le
département du gard merci à tous les
deux